it's now official the tunisian electoral  commission says baiji kai desepsi will  be the country's next president  the 88 year old won sunday's runoff with  nearly 56 percent of the vote  but with his exit poll results pointing  the way a sepsi didn't wait to declare  victory on election night he addressed  his jubilant supporters in tunis  today is the beginning of the future  we hope we will be united i pay tribute  to our people women men and girls  we thank them for their trust  a sepsi heads the nida tunes party he  campaigned on an anti-islamist platform  and has promised to restore the prestige  of the state  but his opponent president monsev mazuki  had warned that a win for a sepsis could  result in a return to the country's old  authoritarian ways  but for now tunisians can celebrate a  victory for democracy their first free  presidential election is the culmination  of the arab spring revolution of four  years ago